hola rodrigo buenas tardes pues
claramente este es un nuevo episodio de
la denominada persecución religiosa que
está llevando a cabo la dupla ortega y
murillo en nicaragua en este momento
este martes se encuentra como usted bien
lo decía un cerco un asedio alrededor de
la iglesia divina misericordia en se
bajo estés al norte del país
centroamericano y al interior de esta
casa cural está encerrado sin poder
salir el párroco de esta iglesia el cura
uriel vallejos él se encuentra con seis
personas pero no pueden salir los
policías les les impiden el hecho de que
puedan incluso entrar alimentos y
bebidas y esto como una demostración de
fuerza de parte del gobierno
ortega murillo en contra de la diócesis
de matagalpa que se está diócesis que es
dirigida por monseñor rolando josé
álvarez uno de los más fuertes críticos
de daniel ortega que de hecho desde el
año 2018 desde la crisis ha solicitado
la liberación de 190 presos políticos y
que desde las radios católicas envía un
mensaje contrario al que mantiene el
gobierno de manera tal que ya son 20
horas las que este párroco es se
encuentra encerrado y 20 horas desde el
asedio en el cual irrumpieron fuerzas
antimotines con bases látex con balazos
gases lacrimógenos para apropiarse
adueñarse de todos los equipos de estas
radios católicas y que dejar por fuera a
estas radios de el sistema de
telecomunicaciones y correos telcor y
andrés contra la human righs watch que
otras reacciones internacionales se han
generado por estos hechos
bueno la dejamos rightswatch es bastante
fuerte la hace tamara taraciuk ella es
la subdirectora era la directora en
funciones ahora con juanita mover tus
que llegó al cargo pues ella es la
subdirectora y hoy se pronunció
haciéndole un llamado vehemente al papá
francisco diciéndole que considerando
todos los hechos de represión de daniel
ortega le pregunta qué más hace falta
para que el papá francisco se pronuncie
contundentemente sobre los abusos de
nicaragua y además dice que hay una
persecución religiosa como haber
expulsado el anuncio del vaticano haber
expulsado a las monjas de la orden de
calcuta y se necesita que en nicaragua
el papá francisco se pronuncie para
salvaguardar la libertad religiosa de
los nicaragüenses